je veux laisser la parole un petit mot
pas le président du conseil général le
conseil départemental mais remercie pour
votre invitation vraiment un petit mot
sur les normes
allons jusqu'au bout prescripteurs
payeur parce que la france est vraiment
atypique en europe et une partie des
difficultés de l'agriculture se trouve
là aussi parlant des départements de
cette collectivité un peu un peu méconnu
et mal traitée par le gouvernement en
fait cette collectivité départementale
c'est c'est celle qui met en oeuvre la
solidarité avec les plus fragiles
d'entre nous personnes âgées personnes
handicapées personnes au rsa enfance en
difficulté qui vous êtes acteur de lien
social très fort sur les territoires
dans les familles porteur d'un gros
secteurs d'activités en milieu rural
notamment les services à la personne
c'est aussi les acteurs de solidarité
territoriale en parfaite coordination
avec les intercommunalités
nous devons réparer cette fracture
territoriale dans toute cette france
rurale dit france d'à côté que ce
pouvoir socialiste a vraiment
marginalisés il ya eu la loi matam où on
a concentré sur treize ou quatorze
grandes métropoles l'ensemble où
l'essentiel des moyens publics ont fait
porter sur l'ensemble des territoires là
même le même fardeau en tire en termes
de de réduction de participation la
réduction des déficits et pour les
départements et qui met en oeuvre la
solidarité nationale prescrite par
l'état à hauteur de 17 18 milliards
d'euros l'état depuis deux ans a oublié
de nous rembourser en moyenne entre 7 et
8 milliards d'euros
aujourd'hui les départements sont dans
la plus grande difficulté dix
départements 10 conseils départementaux
n'ont pas équilibrer leurs comptes en
46 ne le feront pas en 2016 et un
cabinet spécialiste incontesté de de
tous le cabinet klopfer prévoit par
asphyxie financière et donc à se poser
la question d'une volonté politique
puisque au départ on voulait la
suppression des départements cette
collectivité de proximité qui soit
disant ne sert à rien par asphyxie
financière
on va obtenir ce que noah pas obtenu de
par la loi et en 2018
l'ensemble des départements seraient
tombées ce qui pose un problème énorme
pour la solidarité
mais surtout la solidarité territoriale
parce que les intercommunalités ont bien
besoin de cette fédération des
départements souvent les conseils
départementaux consacre aux politiques
de solidarité territoriale
plus du quart voire 30% du produit
fiscal qu'ils vont lever sur l'ensemble
de leur contrée de mercy